Moscow they have these amazing subway
station with great arches and
chandeliers and marble floors and
they're spotless their subways they
should remind us of like the American
master bathroom like with so much marble
and really luxurious
then their bathrooms remind us of our
subway I wish we had world-class
airports in New York City you land at a
great airport you should then be able to
get on like a high-speed train that
brings you right to the heart of town
we're not as good as third world Airport
so let's put it that way I wish we could
bring the great food halls of Europe
into New York in a much better way you
think of the great food laws in Florence
or Madrid or many many many citizen
London and there should be one in every
single neighborhood
I would pull Sydney's stereo system into
the city of New York you've got this
amazing spot like right near the Opera
House where you have a highway you have
rail you've got streetcars you've got
ferries you've got parks you've got the
opera house and that an intermodal
combination is really what helped Sydney
grow I would love to see New York have
more of a working waterfront again the
way they've built in places like Hamburg
and Rotterdam where we keep building
these luxury rental towers like a Duane
Reade on the bottom and think it's
mixed-use you know there are a lot of
cities around the world that are
building new forms of working waterfront
where there's like office and tech space
mixed in with residential and affordable
housing then that would spur a ferry
system that would be really great and
it's just a really different way of
thinking about the city